the jurgen experience logan paul went
eight rounds with the greatest boxer
that's ever lived
dude i mean like you you there was no
cause there's like
you know many people and i think logan
paul is aware of this
we're looking forward to the
satisfaction of watching logan paul
being knocked out by a great buck so
there was a sense of like we are going
to see the hand of justice in the
world you can't just decide you're going
to fight the greatest boxer that ever
lived
and come out of that unscathed you're
dead we were watching it the way we
like people used to watch gladiator
things where they would like
you know put the [ __ ] short-faced
bear out and like let the gladiator
fight it you know what's gonna happen
the bear is gonna eat the [ __ ]
gladiator but but not in this case
in this case it didn't happen but here's
my
you know it's i wrote an instagram post
about it today because i was i was
genuinely
all day i was thinking before we got
before i got here when i was at the gym
i was working out
and i was thinking i was like there's
something about that that's really
intriguing to me
like what is it yeah and i tried to
figure out what it was like what about
the novelty of the moment like
you me tom segura tony hinchcliffe
ron white and curtis curtis nelson we're
all sitting
in my house we couldn't wait the thing
is about to happen we were all like i
can't believe this is happening
i can't believe this is happening we're
looking at them across the ring from
each other
jake paul's like three feet taller than
i'm like this is bananas this is so
wild and he survived and
floyd made with him like 100 million
dollars he'd
he made like a hundred million dollars
fighting a guy who had never
won a professional boxing league [ __ ]
the annoying thing
it's amazing the announcers weren't
acknowledging what was
happening which was like what the [ __ ]
the problem is they had too many people
talking they had a lot of people talking
about this does morrow
yeah how do you say the name desu
sumero um who's the other guy uh
maura now already said and there was one
other gentleman the guy who got in the
ring and
interviewed uh floyd and uh
anyway there was one two three four guys
talking which is a lot of people talking
it's hard to do it's it's but
it would have been nice to have options
this is what you said
if there was an optional stream we could
listen to like teddy atlas
yeah like a boxing expert so because
those guys were being funny and they
were having a good time and everything
like that which is great
and that i think that like comes from
triller you know trailer like you have
snoop dogg [ __ ] around oh yeah no no
i get it i understand what the reason
was behind it but
sitting next i'm not like i don't watch
boxing a lot so it's cool to be sitting
next to you and you're like
oh look he's like trying to drain him or
oh look he [ __ ] up because in the very
beginning he expended too much energy
these are things i don't i don't even
know so that's all just it just added a
dimension to it
there was i was trying to break it down
technically i'm like there's some
interesting things that are happening
here
like first of all floyd is consistently
putting pressure on him and moving and
putting pressure on him and moving
putting pressure on him and after the
third and fourth round
everything comes out a little slower so
he has to be more measured so what floyd
is doing like is
consistently engaging with him and then
pulling out
and consistently engaging and making him
swing and miss and swing a mess
it's brilliant for people that got mad
at it
i get it it's not manny pacquiao versus
floyd mayweather five years ago but what
it is is
one of the best boxers of all time
making a hundred million dollars
fighting a guy who's three feet taller
than them and 35 pounds heavier than who
can't win
yeah it's amazing it's amazing it's
amazing dude that fight was amazing
and there's a lot of amazing things
first of all floyd's amazing
the fact that floyd has the balls at 44
years old
to decide oh i'm just going to go ahead
and fight some dude who's
35 pounds heavier than me right 26 years
old it's crazy
it's crazy and then the fact that he
could put it on
a guy like logan paul and here's another
one
the fact that logan paul went all eight
rounds that's astounding
you have no idea how tired you would be
if you were boxing with
the greatest boxer that's ever lived i
mean maybe he's not
the greatest because that's subjective
but in my opinion he's the greatest
the reason why he's the greatest in my
opinion is he's only been hit hard and
hurt like three times
his whole [ __ ] career there's no one
that can say that
the art of boxing has always been hit
and not get hit
and in my mind no one's ever done that
better than floyd mayweather yeah now
here he is in his 40s he's made
hundreds of millions of dollars fighting
people who have really no chance of
beating him
yeah yeah that's crazy man it's amazing
dude the controversy of the day
uh oh people think he got knocked down
he got knocked down he's being held up
right now over here
people are so silly what if you don't
understand they don't understand [ __ ]
about getting hit in the head
these are the same dummies he's just
hanging on man he's just
he went for an overhook you guys have no
idea this position right here
high elbow going in for an overhook if
he was wrestling he would go back the
other way and throw him on his back
this is a normal thing for a wrestler
logan was a wrestler
in fact in fact ready for this see how
he's got that high overhook on the
left-hand side watch how this happens
again
this is what happens when a bunch of
people comment on fights that don't know
[ __ ]
you see that high overhook that watch
watch one more time
so they they he hits them and now look
at logan's
right arm watch what happens excuse me
left arm see what happens
he's in control he's holding on to it
right right right
he's a wrestler not going limp my friend
guy
sacco who runs defense soap he that's
his company he owns that company that i
rave about all the time
he told me today that logan paul was one
of his wrestlers
in the 1990s and he said he was really
[ __ ] good
he says really talented kid there's a
video of him wrestling
with paulo costa who is a ufc who is
is a rather excuse me a ufc middleweight
contender
like a beast of a guy and logan [ __ ]
scrambles on this guy and like he looks
really good like he can [ __ ] wrestle
so when you see that
and he's not knocked out you
knuckleheads he stopped talking about
fighting
he's holding on yeah and he's protecting
himself and he's controlling floyd and
he's pushing his head to floyd's chest
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience